Donald Trump put out a really bizarre
campaign like commercial and spent
millions on airtime for this this is so
weird
Trump had his first hundred days in
office as you probably have heard by now
and he put out a commercial that is the
type of thing you would expect during a
campaign basically congratulating
himself for everything that he did
during the first hundred days let's play
to begin with just the first six seconds
of this delusional piece of filmmaking
in the first six seconds you already
have ally Donald Trump sworn in as
president 100 days ago America has
rarely seen such success so it's true
yes he was sworn in a hundred days ago
America has rarely seen such success the
only way that that would be true is if
you mean such a lack of success and I
don't think that that's what Trump meant
here but at least they told the truth
Trump was sworn in about a hundred days
ago let's now check out the rest of this
bizarre ad as a respected Supreme Court
justice confirmed companies investing in
American jobs again America becoming
more energy independent regulations that
kill American jobs eliminated the
biggest tax cut plan in history you
wouldn't know it from watching the news
America is winning and President Trump
is making America great again
I'm Donald Trump and I approve this
message okay so a couple different
things number one it sounds like a
campaign ad and technically it is a
campaign Donald Trump filed for
re-election on January 20th inauguration
day we've talked about this before this
allows him to keep raising money this
even provides him some protections from
criticism from certain types of
nonprofits so yes Donald Trump is
currently campaigning from a legal point
of view this is officially a campaign ad
number one okay let's get that out of
the way number two how funny is it that
if you weren't watching you wouldn't
have noticed this Trump says he's been
able to do this the commercial says
Trump has been in it been able to have
all these successes despite all the
negative press about him and it shows
fake news on the screen the entire
commercial is quoting the same media
outlets that Trump is criticizing for
the achievements it said Keystone XL
pipeline source New York Times Trump is
sourcing from the same media outlets
that he says are the problem to tout his
own successes I didn't even notice that
the first time around it's hard to fail
that much in a 30 second advertisement
yeah but also because this is a campaign
style ad we should put out a counter of
this that kind of shows a montage of his
different failures in his first hundred
days so for example not even allowing
the American Health Care Act to go to
the floor of the house because they knew
it was going to fail yeah or the two
executive orders on the Muslim bands
that got struck down what are Trump's
other major failures certainly the
sanctuary city order which fell apart we
can add that on to the items that you
listed what are what else are like his
major failures I'm kind of thinking
those are those are the major ones
obviously the completely abortive Yemen
raid the pointless Syria airstrikes I
would include that in the failures as
well and he wanted to get the tax plan
done in his first 100 days that at least
for now has been pushed off the border
wall funding is going to be delayed as
well but yeah going to do that right
away it's a lot of losing not winning
that I'm noticing so many by the way the
video had so many dislikes on YouTube
that it was taken down and then re
uploaded to reset the dislike counter
and then again it's just over
we dislike a video the real bravery from
Trump though is uploading that
commercial to YouTube and leaving
comments on that actually is the one act
of bravery that the Trump administration
has participated in I was going to say
because you can disable the comments and
you can also disable the ratings not
just do that instead of re uploading it
and trying to hope for a better rating
if you put out a campaign ad when you're
already president and nobody else is yet
running against you things must not be
going particularly well for you